- AND WE'RE COMING TO THE END
OF THE FIRST QUARTER
WITH THE RHINOS IN THE RED ZONE
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
- GOTTA SAY, BILL, I LIKE
WATCHING THESE RHINOS.
- RANSOM TAKES THE SNAP,
DROPS BACK WITH GOOD PROTECTION,
AND THAT'S A COMPLETED PASS
TO A VERY WIDE-OPEN
HINGLE MCCRINGLEBERRY,
THE ROOKIE OUT OF PENN STATE.
- NICE GRAB BY MCCRINGLEBERRY.
YOU THINK HE'S HAPPY?
- OH, BOY, HE IS LOVING IT
DOWN THERE.
- OH, WE GOT SOMETHING
OF A SHOOTING GALLERY GOING ON.
- YEAH, LOOK AT THAT.
BOY, THAT IS SOMETHING, AND--
OH, WAIT, WE'VE GOT
A FLAG THERE.
IS THAT
FOR EXCESSIVE CELEBRATION?
OH, SEE, I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT THAT CALL.
- I DON'T KNOW, BILL.
THAT WAS THREE PUMPS,
AND THE RULEBOOK SAYS
YOU CANNOT HAVE MORE THAN TWO.
- OH, MY GOSH,
BUT LOOK AT THE KID.
HE'S PLEADING HIS CASE
WITH THE REF.
PLEADING HIS CASE.
- YEAH, CLEARLY THREE PUMPS.
- COACH JOHNSON
DEFINITELY NOT HAPPY
ABOUT THIS CALL.
- TWO PUMPS!
- FIVE MINUTES
INTO THE FOURTH QUARTER,
THIRD AND TEN, THE RHINOS AGAIN
THREATENING TO SCORE.
CAN THE COUGARS HOLD THEM?
- BIG PLAY COMING HERE, BILL.
- RANSOM TAKES THE SNAP,
DROPS BACK,
HE FLOATS ONE
INTO THE END ZONE,
AND MCCRINGLEBERRY
PULLS IT DOWN.
- HE'S GOT IT.
- OH, MY GOSH.
FOR HIS SECOND TOUCHDOWN
OF THE DAY FOR THIS ROOKIE,
HE HAS GOTTA BE FEELING GREAT
ABOUT HIMSELF.
- NICELY DONE.
I'LL TELL YOU, MAN, HE'S--
- OH, OH, SEE,
NOW THERE'S TWO PUMPS.
- YEAH, HE'S REALLY TESTING
THE BOUNDARIES,
AND HE'S CLEARLY
GOTTEN THE REF'S ATTENTION HERE.
- A THIRD PUMP WILL DRAW A FLAG
NO MATTER WHAT.
- [blows whistle]
- SEE--OH, HE JUST DID IT AGAIN.
NOW WHAT IS THAT,
THE SECOND TIME?
NOW YOU HAVE
TO FLAG HIM ON THIS.
- YEAH, HE HAD TO.
YOU KNOW, BILL,
IT'S JUST FRUSTRATING
SEEING YOUNG PLAYERS
WITHOUT THE ABILITY
TO RESTRAIN THEMSELVES.
- NO, IT REALLY IS.
IT'S HARD.
- I MEAN, THE REF'S
GONNA GET YOU EVERY TIME.
- YEAH.
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
SEE, NOW THE REF AGREES
THAT'S THREE PUMPS
RIGHT THERE.
AND THE QUARTERBACK RANSOM
UNDER CENTER.
LAST FIVE MINUTES OF THE GAME.
THE RHINOS
ARE MARCHING HERE AGAIN.
- HARD TO STOP THIS TEAM
FROM SCORING, BILL.
THEY HAVE SO MANY WEAPONS.
- RANSOM TAKES THE SNAP.
AND IT'S A SHOVEL PASS
TO MCCRINGLEBERRY, WHO--
HE'S AT THE 10.
HE'S AT THE 5.
AND TOUCHDOWN, RHINOS.
- OH, MY.
GREAT BLOCK BY HARDUNKICHUD,
AND THAT'S GONNA BE
TOUGH FOR THE COUGARS
TO COME BACK FROM.
- BOY, WHAT A CAREER DAY
FROM HINGLE MCCRINGLEBERRY,
THE ROOKIE OUT OF PENN STATE.
OH, HE WAS JUST AMAZINGLY
FIRED UP HERE TODAY, JIM.
- YOU GOTTA LOVE
THE WAY THIS GUY PLAYS,
AND HE--
both: OHH.
- SEE, NOW THERE'S ONE PUMP.
- UH-OH.
- I CANNOT BELIEVE THIS KID.
- YOU GOT TO PUT YOUR TEAM FIRST
IN SITUATIONS LIKE THIS,
AND MCKRINGLEBERRY'S
JUST NOT DOING THAT.
- NOW THERE'S TWO.
JEFF, NOW IF HE PUMPS
A THIRD TIME,
HE WILL DRAW HIS THIRD PENALTY
FOR TODAY.
EVERYBODY HERE WAITING
WITH BATED BREATH.
- HE DID IT.
- OH, DID HE?
- YES, HE DID IT.
- OH. THAT'S JUST--
- COULDN'T HELP HIMSELF.
- THAT'S JUST AMAZING.
I MEAN, COME ON,
IN PROFESSIONAL FOOTBALL--
- IT'S A SHAME.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
- YES, YES, IT IS.
- YOU CAN ARGUE ALL YOU WANT,
BUT THE FLAG, WELL,
IT'S BEEN THROWN.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
IF IT'S THREE PUMPS,
THE REF'S
NOT GONNA TAKE IT AWAY NOW.
- NO, HE'S NOT.
DURATION AND INTENSITY
DOESN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE.
- WELL, JEFF, LET'S HAVE A LOOK
AT THE REPLAY HERE
TO SEE IF INDEED HE DID DO
THE THREE PUMPS.
- ALL RIGHT. NO QUESTION.
THERE IS THE FIRST ONE, RIGHT?
- YEAH. AGREED.
- AND THEN COMING UP
IS THE SECOND ONE.
- OKAY.
- YES, VERY CLEAR.
IT'S THE THIRD--
- WE'LL SEE IT.
IT'S COMING UP RIGHT HERE.
- I'M JUST NOT SURE.
OH, YEAH,
YOU'RE RIGHT.
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
THREE PUMPS THERE.
- OH.
- UH, APOLOGIES TO ALL
THOSE WATCHING
WITH YOUNG CHILDREN.
CLEARLY UNINTENTIONAL.